I'm very pleased to introduce Misha
Glenny you I'm sure everyone in this
room knows who he is he's been writing
for all sorts of people
iris dates me but I remember when he was
covering the Balkans for the Guardian
which is a very long time ago
Misha Glenny also writes for The New
Yorker the New York Times The New York
Review of Books
he's been not only well-known as a sort
of expert in Russia and the Balkans but
he's written two books recently
published two books recently which I
thought would make him a really
interesting speaker for this conference
one was macmurphy Oh which was about the
rise of organized crime and Misha Glen
he talks a lot about the relationship of
organized crime and transition economies
and then dart market which was a sort of
compelling and riveting but also a
thorough exhaustive sort of definitive
book on the hacking community and sort
of cyber criminals around the world so
I'm really happy to have Misha Glenny
doing the keynote because he's moving
away a little bit from the sort of
conventional Russian media discussion
that we've been having today which has
been fantastic and taking us into the
seamy and dark and perhaps not so see me
a dark side of the Russian Internet
thank you very much for speaking here
today and I should add that Misha Glenny
and his wife are visiting at SEPA this
spring sponsored by Harriman my program
I'm AG and the committee so we're just
been very happy to have you here at
Columbia this semester thanks very much
Hannah this is billed as a keynote
speech it's actually going to be more of
a keynote chat with plenty of
informality thrown in and I don't even
mind being interrupted for questions and
that sort of thing because some of the
things I'm going to talk about are
likely to be unfamiliar to to some of
you you never know and really what I'm
going to do is to look not so much at
the media as we understand it as a form
of
of Public Communication but the medium
of the internet and how its developed in
certain ways that are not always built
visible inside Russia and some of the
other CIS countries notably Ukraine and
this interest of mine emerged after the
research I did on my last book dark
market which is really an attempt to map
apart a quite important part of the
global cyber underworld over the past 15
years or so and anyone who engages with
the cyber underworld looking perhaps
initially at conventional criminal
activity on the internet very quickly
comes into contact with other actors
involved in this world not the least of
which are the intelligence agencies of
most major powers and that's going to be
one of the things I'm going to be
concentrating on in the next few minutes
as I speak so my initial interest in
this subject was sparked by the fact
that it was a group of Ukrainian hackers
and advanced computer users who in the
year 2001 came up with the brilliant
technique for overcoming what is the
central challenge facing anyone involved
in criminal activity on the Internet and
that central challenge is how can you do
business with somebody on the Internet
if you're engaged in criminal activity
when it's axiomatic that they're
untrustworthy because they're criminals
so you have to find a way of
establishing trust and that's very
difficult indeed and then this rather
brilliant
of Ukrainian hackers based in Odessa
where else came up with this operation
or which was a website called cada
planet wwr planet.com
and cada planet was a very brilliant
thing I don't know if any of you use
forums on the internet for discussing
your discussing your problems we have a
very well known forum in the United
Kingdom called Mumsnet which is for
people who have parenting problems for
example so you know if you've you go
onto the internet and you go to the
section entitled
teenagers and you put in a question
saying you know I've just found a packet
of condoms in my 13 year old daughters
draw what do I do and lots of people
will write back and say this is how you
solve that particular problem and it's a
way of engaging with the community that
you need to get to very quickly it's a
very effective thing the forum
discussion so well what card a planet
was was the first and one of the most
successful forums for criminals so if
you were an internet criminal you would
sign on to www.engvid.com for sale and
this is where you have your problem how
do you know because you're dealing with
a criminal that those 5,000 debit cards
are actually debit cards which you can
use to engage in criminal activity and
steal money and this is where the genius
of car the planet
and its founders its administrators who
went rather unimaginative Lee under the
name the family this is where their idea
came in which was very brilliant and it
was called the escrow system so one of
the five administrators of the website
said right okay this is what we're going
to do we are we have appointed an escrow
officer so if you have your five
thousand debit or credit card stolen
debit or credit cards for sale you then
send it digitally to the escrow officer
and the person who wants to buy the
credit and debit cards sends digitally
the money that he usually at this time
around two thousand a functioning stolen
debit card would cost between about 20
and 40 dollars so you'd send twenty
times five thousand dollars to the
escrow officer the escrow officer would
then digitally send the details of a
random sample of these debit cards to
his friends in Toronto in Rio in
Wellington in almaty all over the place
and they would test them on ATM machines
and they would take the money out and
they would keep the money as a fee for
the service send some of it back to the
escrow officer and if they worked all
over the world the escrow officer would
then release the debit cards to the
purchaser hands the money to the vendor
and this led to an extraordinary
explosion in criminal activity all over
the world based around debit and credit
cards and it's known as carding hence
card a planet and this was a wild
success and particularly in the first
couple of years it within about six
months there were seven or eight
thousand active members of card our
planet and and I will talk about the the
media in Russia a little bit now
probably one of the publications which
has been amongst the most influential in
Russia over the past 15 years but which
very people few people know about is a
magazine an online magazine called
hacker
you and there is not a single system
computer system in the world which
hasn't featured in one form or another
in the monthly publication of Hakka are
you which you can go and read online it
is absolutely amazing it is a Bible for
those of you who want to hack and can
speak Russian not only that
unlike most magazines about computers
they have long interviews with some of
the most renowned and famous hackers and
criminals in Russia it's an incredibly
useful for a resource for those of you
who are investigating this sort of this
sort of thing so anyway so hacker are
you had some great articles including a
long interview with one of the founders
of car the planet a man named script
whose real name is Dmitry golubov or
hollow buff depending on whether your
cranium speaking of Russian speaking and
Dmitry is now president of the internet
party in Ukraine with aspirations to
become a leading political figure in
Ukraine anyway in an earlier version
Dmitri was the founder of cada planet
and it was such a success that in June
2001 the founders of cada planet
resolved to hold in adesso
the first ever worldwide carding
conference
international worldwide carding
conference and this is true from May the
30th to June the second cyber criminals
from all over the world descended upon
Odessa and the plenary sessions were
held in the hotel Odessa I don't know
for those of you who've been to Edessa
the hotel Odessa is the best place to
say because it's the only place in
Odessa that you can't see the hotel
Odessa and it's right at the bottom of
the Potemkin steps so you know there's a
kind of those film aficionados amongst
you there's a sort of you know freestyle
every time you look out of the window
and then the breakout sessions were held
in restaurant
and bars all over Odessa and the
breakout sessions were very interesting
they had sort of specialist areas of why
do we concentrate so much on MasterCard
and Visa shouldn't we develop our work
on diners cards and things like that as
well and so one of the things I was able
to do I was very very proud of this was
to get hold of the press release for the
first ever international worldwide
carden's conference and there in the
press release
it was absolutely crystal clear about
this how how this whole thing functioned
because you would have thought that in
some way like Russia and Ukraine you
would have thought that possibly these
characters were not being observed by
certain agencies and if they were being
observed by certain agencies you would
have thought that those agencies might
have taken some active interest in their
work well you would have been right but
perhaps you wouldn't have been right as
to the particular type of interest that
those activities took in their work so
here we are first well okay resolution
one any kada found attacking the
financial institutions of the Russian
Federation Belarus Ukraine and other
member countries of the CIS shall be
excluded from the cauda planet community
immediately . so very very clear there
so i fortunately when i was doing the
research for dark market managed to
track down one of the members of the
family who was at the first worldwide
international Cardoz conference and he
was actually responsible responsible for
carter planets surveillance and security
operation to try and see who those
agencies were and what those agencies
were doing when it came to the
activities of the conference and he
explained to me very explicitly what the
deal was when they were approached less
by the SBU
more by the FSB but the SBU at the time
this is in 2000 2001 is essentially a
sort of filial company of the FSB and
the FSB certainly has what to señor over
activities like these and the SBU the
Ukrainian security service of course
also had far fewer funds available for
the development of its cyber resources
than the FSB does and we'll come on to
what the FSB is able to do a little
later on anyway they were eventually
approached quite directly and they had
negotiations as the carding community of
the CIS with the FSB and this is the
deal that was struck you are entitled to
steal all the credit cards and debit
cards you like from Western Europe the
United States Japan Middle East South
Africa wherever as long as you don't
touch anything in the former Soviet
Union and as soon as you do touch
anything in the former Soviet Union you
will be getting a virtual knock on the
door at four o'clock in the morning so
that was the first part of the deal so
they are monitoring what is going on
with the carding and the criminal
community and they're also monitoring
the types of skills that are being
developed in the criminal web world and
what lessons or you know how instructive
this might be for them at at a later
date so that was that was one part of
the deal now quarter planet as I say
became hugely famous and hugely popular
it was eventually it eventually closed
down for a variety of reasons a lot to
do with internal problems one or two of
the characters were arrested not
actually in Ukraine or Russia but
elsewhere the entire site had by this
time being pet been penetrated not just
by the FSB and the SBU but
by the US Secret Service by mi6 in the
UK and so on and so forth now when they
they penetrate these sites they often
pose as members themselves and they're
attempting to do two things they're
attempting to build cases for possible
criminal investigation and prosecution
but they were they are also doing is
they're attempting to identify what kind
of weapons tools and techniques that
these criminals on the Internet
are developing because they're very
useful weapons tools and techniques so
that's what was going on with Carter
planning to collapse but Ukraine Russia
and Belarus but in particular Russia and
Ukraine developed a tremendous
reputation for having the most efficient
effective under underworld on the
internet around the globe the other
great incubator of cyber criminal
activity on the web was perhaps
surprisingly Brazil and Brazil is still
a major exporter of cyber criminal
activity increasingly so is China but
perhaps more of that a little bit a
little bit later anyway so the first
deal is don't touch our institutions now
in the meanwhile people like the efforts
the the FBI and the US Secret Service in
the United States Postal Inspection
Service are very interested in trying to
establish cooperation with the MVD and
the FSB to launch prosecutions over the
rampant cyber crime emanating out of the
former Soviet Union but they largely
reach a reach a brick wall whenever they
whenever they try and do this because of
course the FSB has the deal now the
other part of the deal
that was made explicit to members or
senior members of Carter planet was that
if the Russian Federation or Ukraine
requires the hacking skills of criminals
in the service of national security then
they will jump to it so you began to see
these clusters of hacking activity grow
up in particular parts of the former
Soviet Union including some parts of the
former Soviet Union which were by now
members of the European Union Latvia
most especially and Estonia as well each
of the clusters grew up for different
reasons
odessa's cluster grew up because it was
an incredibly fluid criminal area deeply
corrupt with systems of governance which
were effectively non non functioning but
also there was a fairly significant
amount of criminal control from Russian
groups in Odessa which was sanctioned
and sponsored by the Russian state
because Odessa of course was the only
warm water port for Russian oil exports
and so the influence of the Russian
Federation and Russian criminal groups
in Odessa was very very significant some
Petersburg grew up as a cluster area for
hacking and cyber activity partly under
the influence of the liberalism of San
Petersburg in the early 1990s and partly
because that as that morphed into the
influence of putinism there were
tremendous connections between people
involved in in hacking and in
the FSB if you look at the really
advanced characters involved in computer
technology in Russia you will see and
I'll come to this a little bit later a
lot of people who were involved in
state-sponsored operations in the 1970s
but particularly the 1980s developing
surveillance and other techniques for
use on computers and they went pride it
in the 1990s when budgets for the FSB or
the KGB as it was at the time collapsed
by about 90% in 91 92 93 and have since
developed very successfully businesses
on a private basis but they maintained
their contacts with with the FS FSB but
anyway so you had some Petersburg as a
particularly powerful criminal and
security cluster on the internet Estonia
was very interesting
Estonia provided a small group of very
influential criminal hackers as a
consequence of the fact that one of its
towns on the northern coast
Salima Salameh was a closed facility in
the Soviet Union and it was the facility
where the first nuclear device was
developed in the Soviet Union and of
course what happened when Estonia was
taken over by the Soviets was when
cinema was closed off a lot of Russian
scientists were sent to cinema where
they were working on the nuclear program
and Salama became a very high-level
facility during the Soviet Union when
things collapsed in 1990 partly because
there were no Sates state subsidies left
for closed facilities partly because it
was no
in Russia and partly because of the
resurgence of Estonian nationalism this
was a very very depressed area but it
was a depressed area which had a lot of
extremely smart and technically able
Russians in it and they started selling
their skills to all sorts of people but
what of the point their children
developed the most fantastic computer
skills and out of a cluster of about 12
to 14 young hackers grew a system which
then migrated to Petersburg called the
Russian business Network or the RB m and
the RB n was a network of posters these
are people who provide services if you
want to use the Internet it was
so-called a bulletproof hosting system
that means that nobody from the outside
can tell what you're doing inside those
servers and the rbn became the center
for the largest single amount of spam
email illegal activity of credit card
fraud and that sort of thing but also
child pornography
and so on and so forth during the during
the first decade of the millennium until
it was finally shut down in 2007 2008
and the inspiration for the Russian
business Network as I say was this group
of kids from Salima in Estonia so you
would see this really interesting
clustering of activity going on all over
the place now the first time that the oh
sorry I'm terribly sorry I forgot to
mention one thing by now one of the
reasons why car the planet it Carter
planet is so easily monitored by the FSB
and the SBU is is that the FSB have
introduced legislation for the
implementation of what is called Psalm 2
which is
the system of operative investigative
mechanisms for the entire internet over
Russia and Psalm 2 compels ISPs Internet
service providers to provide all data
that is going across the internet to
storage servers provided by the FSB in
Moscow and elsewhere so the FSB has
access to any activity that is going on
on the Internet in Russia ISPs in the
early 2000s actually tried to go to
court to try and bring Psalm 2 down
partly because the ISPs under the
legislation legislation are required to
pay for this and it's quite an expensive
and onerous business cost for them on
behalf of the Russian state but they
failed comprehensively
and centralized monitoring of the
internet of all Internet activity
including all the live blogging stuff
and all that sort of thing is standard
and par for the course and I'll end up
just by when I finish in five minutes or
so telling you what sort of stuff
they're doing they're doing now with
that anyway so it was 2007 that we had
the first great test of Russia's hacking
capability and its popular hacking
capacity being deployed for national
security purposes and this was the much
fabled attack on Estonia in April and
May 2007 as a consequence of the really
slightly laughable dispute about the
movement of the statute to the Russian
Unknown Soldier from the center of
Tallinn into actually I mean you know
they were one of the strange things
about this is is that it really was
moved more or less just around the
corner I mean it was literally a sort of
mile or two away and it actually I went
to see it in the place where it was
moved to in the cemetery it actually
looked extremely sort of rather moving
around the graceful I
rather nice in its news place anyway
this resulted in the Russians denouncing
the resurgence of Estonian fascism
followed by this extraordinary assault
on Estonia s-- internet system now
Estonia of course is about the most
wired country in Europe and so that
means that it's incredibly advanced in
its use of the internet but it's also
very vulnerable if things go wrong and
this attack on its on its government
websites on its main media websites huge
attacks on its a banking system and
other administrative systems was
absolutely devastating and within three
or four days of this attack taking place
they realized that the only way they
could they could save themselves from
what was going on was to shut off the
Estonian internet from the outside world
and that's what they did and of course
if you shut off the internet from the
outside world you're kind of losing the
point of the internet so but that's what
they did they were astonished by the
computing power that the Russians were
able to generate and they along with the
CIA and indeed one of the guys who was
running the security of the largest
Estonian bank at the time told me that
as he was tracing back the attack of
80,000 zombie computers these are
computers which had come under the
control of a single user who had
successfully infected those 80,000
computers with a virus he was able to
trace it back as far as a server in
Malaysia and what did he discover in
that server in Malaysia he spotted
Internet activity in that server from
both the United States and Israel so the
Estonians who were the actual subject of
the attack were tracing the attack on
their systems
slower than the Americans and the
Israelis which there's a lot in
particular for the Israelis cyber
capacity and I'll mention a tiny little
bit of thing about that later on towards
the end in about five minutes or so so
anyway so there we were huge attack
Estonia more or less brought to its
knees and of course the only way the
Russians could do this was by mobilizing
operations like the rugs Russian
business Network on behalf of national
state security and very successful they
were - as they were next year when they
launched a collateral cyber information
attack on Georgia during the the little
war there in August 2000 2008 so what
you have with the Internet in Russia is
an extraordinary tool which is heavily
weighted in favor of of the state I know
that there is a hope and an optimism
that the blogging community that from
Navalny onwards we are seeing a
community which is actually mobilizing
opposition organizations in the state
and is being able to use the internet
for for progressive political program
but I wouldn't hold your breath about
this we are also seeing at the same time
what the FSB is currently introducing is
the most advanced form of data and
information analysis that is known to
the world this has now also been passed
by the collective security treaty
organisation which is basically Central
Asia Russia Armenia Ukraine and so on
they are all introducing security
analysis on the Internet
which can monitor everything going on on
social media network sites so as soon as
they see anything like let's meet down
the our batter at five o'clock bring
your baseball bats or whatever it is you
want to bring they can identify where
it's coming from who's it going to and
what it probably means and they can be
they're ready for it when it happens
they are developing and deploying around
the internet in Russia speech
recognition techniques which can
identify people even when they are
distorting their voice either digitally
or through the use of accents or change
in pitch and of course their photo
recognition is also extremely advanced
the Russians are beginning to compete
with West European and American
companies in selling surveillance
techniques all over the world and
they're doing a very good job of it now
here we have a real equivalence in terms
of what is going on on the internet as a
whole I think that you'll find that what
we're actually seeing is in the more
global sense a fragmentation of the
internet into national large national
intranets
ie ones which function under a specific
jurisdiction with very specific rules
for that jurisdiction I think you'll see
that in the United States I visited a
couple of weeks ago the largest
information technology annual Jamboree
in the US which is called the RSA
Conference which takes place in San
Francisco and I went to the exhibit hall
and this was frankly the cyber
military-industrial complex at play and
they intend I think to start locking
down the internet in the name of
security wherever possible at the moment
we are seeing this is excluding China
and Russia at the moment the Western
world spends a hundred
billion dollars a year on on security
technologies over the internet and and
over telecommunications and our ability
to use the Internet is being restricted
progressively by states around the world
both democratic states and non
democratic states and they are all
selling each other high-end surveillance
and security technology much of this has
been privatized but much of it has come
out of the state this is the same model
in Russia as it is in Israel and to an
extent the United States so for example
those people who were working as I said
in Russia on high-end computer stuff in
the 1980s for the KGB who left in the
1990s but who retained their friendships
with personnel have either gone back to
the FSB now or they are being used as as
contract companies by the FSB to provide
some advanced surveillance technology in
Israel they extremely intelligently
invested in the late seventies and early
eighties in a very specific unit of the
IDF 8200 which is there to develop
internet offensive and defensive
capability graduates of 8,200 now run
most of the mega corporations that
provide Internet security technologies
to governments around the world the
United States trains up a lot of its
officers in cyber whether it's the CIA
whether it's the military whether it's
the DEA or whether it's the FBI who once
they read reach a certain level of
competence are then poached by Google by
Microsoft by McAfee by Symantec they're
paid ten times the amount that they can
earn as a government employee and of
course they get to live on the west
coast and not in Washington so they all
go and this is a pattern that
emerging pretty much around the world
now I I say this and I'll end up on this
is simply to add a note of caution for
those people who believe that social
media and social media networks are
having a decisive political influence on
political processes around the world I
think the thing that if you look at the
the events in Russia of last year late
last year you could argue that the
internet was a contributory factor but
you could also argue I think that the
putin system was beginning to look tired
and weak from a number of perspectives
within and around the elite as well as
creating a fair amount of popular
discontent so i would caution people who
believe that the internet is having that
decisive impact whether in russia or
whether in the Middle East and elsewhere
and I can guarantee you that all states
currently feeling in the least
threatened by the Internet are entered
under taking very advanced programs in
order to ensure that their power bases
will not be threatened by a political
movement spreading out across the web so
there you have it
that was my keynote chat thank you very
much and I can see Dounia at six o'clock
but I'm happy to answer questions before
then if there are any
Jamin I want you to talk a little bit
about the phenomenal example just a few
months ago comrades
which allows you to do the most was in a
location not too far south appear in the
communications of it well by Twitter and
when people came to the apartment where
the comics was to be used for
demonstration guess who was there and
what he did so the four one nine is
actually for those who don't know what a
four one nine is for one a four one nine
scam for those of you who have received
emails announcing that somebody has left
you fifteen million dollars often
Sani Abacha the late sunny a bachelor a
great president of Nigeria and all you
have to do is get in touch with these
people to organize the transfer of your
money and then when you get in touch
they say absolutely fine the money's all
yours purply send us four thousand
dollars first of all and then we shall
transfer the money after these legal
period fees have been paid and then of
course you never hear from them again
now this is called the four one nine
scam after the particular clause in the
Nigerian Penal Code or the advanced fee
fraud and I first came across I was well
I first came across the full one nine
from when I was I was watching a
production of The Alchemist by Ben
Johnson of great Elizabethan a writer at
the National Theatre and halfway through
I had to restrain myself from standing
up and saying it's a four one nine scam
but the alchemist is an advance fee
fraud so this is a scam that's been
going on for years and years and years
five centuries at least
but what the Internet has done has
enabled it to go global which is
absolutely fabulous and the Nigerians
are particularly engaged in elaborating
in the most theatrical manner possible
the four one nine schemes and I'm very
very fond of
some of this ideas they come up with but
it's really the full 1-9 the four
announce camp is based upon the
assumption to put it in colloquial terms
that there is a sucker born every minute
because if you want out of the blue to
send $5,000 to a bank account in benin
then by all means go ahead and do it
you've clearly got too much money in the
first place so but so it's a particular
type of scan the interesting thing is if
you talk to the UNDP or if you talk to
the World Bank and you say to them what
do you think about the the fact that
there's going to be a fiber optic
internet cable running from Kenya down
to Tanzania they will say this is
fabulous you know Africa's joining the
digital age and it's going to be
absolutely terrific if you pose the same
question to an FBI officer they will put
their head in their hands and say oh my
god the tsunami is coming so that's what
I'd say that's what's happening next
before one line
these skins which is hope I do not come
to you by chance
and the characters are full palace of
people in Lagos and everyone in the
house
is quite simple that equation is the
other way around
the problem is for if they're two issues
with you guys first of all when I
decided to write a book about this
market I was confronted with this
problem and say if you're going to write
a book about computers you have to get
around that fact and so instead about
writing about computers what I did is as
I went and watched a whole load of
Hollywood movies which purport to have
computers at the center and I had
mercifully just read the Magisterial
trilogy of Stieg Larsson the Millennium
Trilogy starting with the girl with the
Dragon Tattoo and I noticed when people
talked to me about it they always said
isn't that amazing what that girl can do
with computers and if you look at the
book it's about sort of 0.5% of the book
is about computers the rest of it is
just a good old political corrupt
criminal beyond very well done for our
age I think an Elizabeth Salander
certainly is a very very credible figure
except for the fact that she's a woman
because 95% of hackers are men but
there's no doubt if she was one of the
five percent there are people with these
extraordinary skills hacking skills
photographic memories advanced maths and
science ability I've met them I've
interviewed them at length and she's
she's wonderful but what I realized from
that and what I realized from
from watching the Hollywood movies which
were 99% bog-standard Hollywood movies
and then every so often someone would
sort of furiously tap at a computer and
say oh my god it's the diet Ron and
that's it I realized that don't write
about computers if you want to write
about computers write about the people
behind the computers so that's why I
tracked down the hackers the cops and
what a strange weird wonderful bunch of
people they all were from all over the
world from all different social
backgrounds as I say the only factor
that is usually the same is the fact
that they're meant but otherwise they're
incredibly different in all sorts of in
all sorts of ways so that's how you try
and start to make computers interesting
because they are I agree with you
intrinsically boring in so many ways in
the question of the technology thing the
differences is is that networked
computers and the Internet it's very
genius lies in its interconnectedness
but that is also where its Achilles heel
lies that this is a technology that is
incredibly sensitive upon which we have
become unbelievably dependent you really
don't know just how dependent we are on
network systems now and how easily if a
network system goes down then the supply
of foodstuffs to shops can can dry up
very quickly the supply of water and so
on and so forth we are hugely dependent
on these systems we have forgotten how
to do certain everyday things when was
the last time anyone remembered a
telephone number for example now you
lose your mobile phone and you can't
remember anyone's numbers to ring up
anymore because we've stored them all on
our phone and we we don't memorize them
anymore so all sorts of things are
changing the way that we we deal with
things and this technology is incredibly
powerful and you are linking up to the
same system
which in across which advanced weaponry
moves as well you're also a
vulnerability we now have advanced cyber
weaponry being developed by over 100
states around the world they use the
techniques of criminals they use you as
a vulnerability because we don't know
about cyber security at all they they
anonymous the great political activist
group of the internet is a very
interesting phenomenon but one with a
real again with an Achilles heel if
you're attacked by anonymous do you know
that you're being attacked by anonymous
or are you being attacked by I don't
know if French intelligence or are you
being attacked by a criminal group and
so what I'm saying is is that this
technology as opposed to technology in
the past is both immensely powerful but
it's also accessed by everyone on a
daily basis in much of their lives and
that means that in terms of the problems
that it causes obviously the convenience
and the fantastic things that it does
goes without saying but the problems it
causes are actually of a different
nature than the problems caused by
telephones or by the book and so I I
mean what I say to people is is that
unfortunately boring though it may be
this is an issue that we have to start
engaging with in particular because I
see states with abandoned now developing
surveillance and control techniques
which it is very easy for them to deploy
without without proper oversight from
from the criminal justice system and so
be wound is all I say but enjoy the
internet in Lima